Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Je dois toucher avec la langue pour
embrasser quand je serai amoureux ?
Parce que, moi, ça me dégoûte. »
Ça, c’est Jérôme, 32 ans,
autiste avec
une déficience intellectuelle.
Franca a toute sa conscience,
toute son intelligence,
mais une maladie dégénérative grave.
Elle a 44 ans.
Elle vit toujours couchée, très amaigrie.
« J’aimerais tant sentir le corps nu
d’un homme contre mon corps nu.
Vous savez, il n’aurait rien
besoin de me faire,
juste d’être collé tout contre moi.
Après tout, ça pourrait aussi
être le corps d'une femme.
Je rêve d’un corps à corps,
nu, doux, chaud et tendre.
Juste une fois. »
Il y a aussi les mots de ce père :
« Notre fils, 19 ans,
handicapé mental profond,
sans langage, ne sait pas se masturber.
Je le vois, il prend des coussins,
il les frotte devant lui parce
qu’il ne veut pas toucher son sexe
mais il ne parvient pas à l’éjaculation.
Je me rends compte
combien cela le met en tension.
Il s’agite, il s’énerve, il s’irrite.
Il va parfois jusqu’à se mordre. »
Quant à Andreas et à Clara,
respectivement 24 et 25 ans,
nés avec une paralysie cérébrale,
vivant dans un foyer handicap,
ils m’avaient confié
et je vous épargne leur manière
très particulière de s’exprimer :
« Nous, on a un grand lit en commun.
Et puis, vous savez,
on a demandé aux soignants
de nous installer en position de 69
parce qu’avec nos jambes spastiques,
de toute façon, quand on est en
face à face, on ne peut rien faire.
Alors, on s’est dit qu’on aimerait essayer
une fois une fellation ou un cuni.
Mais visiblement, les soignants,
ça les gêne beaucoup.
Personne, le silence. »
Et puis, il y aurait Géraldine
avec une trisomie 21
qui est à la recherche d’une amoureuse
mais qui devrait surtout
ne pas être handicapée.
Et puis, il y aurait...
J’ai des centaines d’exemples,
de situations de vécu,
tirés des handicaps physiques,
des handicaps mentaux,
des handicaps psychiques,
des handicaps sensoriels,
que j’ai glanés au cours de nombreuses
années de pratique en sexopédagogie.
Comment ne pas entendre ?
Car nous sommes vraiment
très nombreux à entendre.
Soignants, soignantes,
éducateurs, éducatrices,
rééducateurs, médecins,
thérapeutes, parents.
Et nous leur répondons fréquemment :
« Nous vous comprenons. »
Mais avouons qu’au-delà,
les réponses concrètes
fréquemment manquent.
Parce que s’occuper
de l’intime de l’intime,
pour autrui avec autrui,
c’est très interpellant et c’est délicat.
Alors, qu’en est-il
de leur accès au désir ?
Et à qui appartient-il d’organiser
la réponse à ce désir ?
Chacun, chacune se demande au fond
qui s’en mêle, jusqu’où on s’en mêle,
pour le bénéfice de qui
et avec quelle prise de risque.
Rappelons que le droit à la sexualité
fait partie des droits
fondamentaux de l’Homme.
Or, pour accéder à ce droit,
il faudrait, pour les personnes
en situation de handicap,
mettre en place des aides, des adaptations
et des créativités.
Nos créativités et
respectons aussi les leurs.
Voyons, par exemple, pour Jérôme.
Jérôme regarde des films à la télévision.
Il a intégré qu’embrasser sur la bouche,
si possible avec la langue,
était un code amoureux habituel.
Or, pour les personnes autistes,
très clairement pour lui,
la bouche et son humidité,
l’haleine et son odeur,
la salive et son goût, peuvent entraîner
des sensations de profond dégoût.
Par ailleurs, se conformer
aux normes de la société
leur tient très à cœur.
En effet, les personnes autistes
s’entraînent depuis leur jeune âge
à se conformer aux manières
des personnes dites neurotypiques.
Les neurotypiques, c’est nous.
Donc, en toute légitimité,
Jérôme se demande s’il va être obligé
d’embrasser sur la bouche
et de toucher avec la langue.
D’emblée, on pourrait lui répondre :
« Mais non, personne n’est obligé. »
On peut aimer sans embrasser,
tout en se disant que
c’est peut-être un peu dommage.
C’est vrai,
personnellement, je connais moult
personnes handicapées mentales
qui s’aiment beaucoup sans s’embrasser.
Mais nous devrions aussi
nous poser la question suivante :
« Que va-t-il se passer, Jérôme,
si ton amoureuse ou ton amoureux
souhaite t’embrasser sur la bouche ? »
À cette perspective, Jérôme m’a répondu :
« Alors, j’essayerai
pour lui faire plaisir.
Mais je lui demanderai d’abord
de bien s’essuyer la bouche,
de bien la sécher et surtout
de garder la langue dedans. »
Voilà, ça, c’est la créativité
déclinée à la manière autiste.
Andreas et Clara, eux, m’ont
demandé de parler aux soignants.
Ces derniers m’ont répondu :
« Attendez, ce n’est pas
tout à fait notre rôle, n’est-ce pas,
de les mettre en position de 69.
D’ailleurs, imaginez si monsieur
avait déjà une érection
au moment de la mise au lit. »
Ponctuellement, c’est pourtant leur rôle.
Car selon la paralysie cérébrale,
les personnes concernées
ne peuvent absolument pas
mouvoir leur corps elles-mêmes.
Nous travaillons cette implication
délicate dans les formations.
Néanmoins, une autre réaction
pourrait survenir.
Et celle-ci, personne n’y avait songé.
Même pas les deux protagonistes.
Qu’un spasme se déclenche
dans la bouche de madame
au moment de l’accueil du pénis.
Et alors ?
A cette évocation, ils ont éclaté de rire
et Clara a dit : « Ouf !
Heureusement qu’ils ne nous ont
jamais mis dans cette position
parce que tu te rends compte,
j’aurais pu te croquer. »
Néanmoins, elle a tourné
sa tête vers moi et elle a dit :
« Mais comme ce n’est pas certain
qu’un spasme se déclenche,
est-ce qu’on ne pourrait pas
tout de même essayer
avec une carotte ou une courgette ? »
Très bonne idée,
c’est une autre créativité, voyez-vous.
Tout l’enjeu est là.
Lorsqu’il y a dépendance physique,
psychique ou mentale,
un tiers,
ce dernier va devoir se mêler
de l’intimité affective et sexuelle
d’une personne qui, si elle ne
vivait pas avec un handicap,
se débrouillerait seule avec sa sexualité.
Ce tiers devient voyeur de fait.
Il peut être professionnel ou parent.
Et ceci n'est pas banal.
Revenons au père face à l’incapacité
de masturbation de son fils.
Quel père ici serait habituellement voyeur
des masturbations de son fils de 19 ans ?
Vertige.
Il n’est de loin pas le seul.
Ne pas savoir se masturber
peut sembler étrange.
Et pourtant, pour certains,
il faudrait leur apprendre.
Et je dis certains parce
que pour les certaines,
les femmes,
lorsque l’une d’elles sans possibilité
de s’exprimer à cet égard,
frotte avec ses mains son entre-jambes,
qui pourrait se permettre
d’aller regarder de tout près ?
Est-elle dans une stimulation de ses
petites lèvres, de ses grandes lèvres ?
De son clitoris ?
De l’entrée de son vagin ?
Ou de tout à la fois ?
Vertige vertigineux.
On leur apprend pourtant bien
à se laver les dents
mais pour un apprentissage
d’ordre si intime,
qui serait habilité à le prodiguer ?
D’ailleurs, comment deviner
les sensations utiles à l’autre ?
Le rythme, l'intensité des frottements.
Vertige.
Dans les institutions, dans les familles,
des jeunes adultes, ou des moins jeunes,
traversent des épisodes
de violence contre eux-mêmes,
voire parfois contre autrui,
qui sont l’expression
de cette tension sexuelle non apaisée.
Quelle aide possible pour sortir
de ces états de tension ?
Vertige encore.
Nous avions misé
sur l’assistance sexuelle thérapeutique
qui s’exercerait sur le corps directement
avec la participation de la personne
directement concernée.
Mais nous n'en sommes qu'aux prémices
parce qu'il s'avère que cette pratique
est plus complexe
que nous ne l’avions pensé.
L’assistance sexuelle.
Cette subtile suppléance.
Pour Franca.
Un assistant sexuel
fut convié chez Franca.
Le rendez-vous du corps
à corps fut d’une sobriété.
Souvenez-vous, elle avait dit :
« Il n’aura rien besoin de me faire. »
L’assistant sexuel avait suggéré
préalablement à Franca de choisir,
si elle le souhaitait,
une musique de fond.
La voix libanaise de Sœur Marie Keyrouz
accompagna leur nudité durant une heure.
Franca ne demanda pas
de deuxième rendez-vous.
Elle voulut celui-ci comme
exceptionnel et unique.
Il le fut.
Qui aurait pu répondre
à la solitude de son corps ?
Franca n'a pas de partenaire.
Certainement pas son frère, ni sa sœur,
ni son médecin, ni son physiothérapeute.
Car voyez-vous,
la sexualité commence déjà là.
Tout simplement.
Deux corps allongés nus
l’un contre l’autre.
Sans excitation,
sans rien avoir à prouver.
Et si, dans cette tranquille douceur,
des caresses naissaient spontanément,
alors, tant mieux.
Après le Danemark,
l’Allemagne, la Hollande et l’Autriche,
l’assistance sexuelle s’est installée
en Suisse allemande en 2000
grâce à feue Aïha Zemp.
Elle-même est née
sans bras et sans jambes.
Je l’ai connue et je l’ai admirée.
Femme-tronc rayonnante, dynamique,
psychothérapeute et féministe engagée.
Et si j’évoque son handicap,
c’est pour souligner, une fois de plus,
la compétence et la créativité
des personnes elles-mêmes concernées.
En Suisse romande, nous avons initié
deux formations en assistance sexuelle
et ce furent les premières
en langue francophone.
La première en 2008, la deuxième en 2014
et nous avons formé d’abord
six femmes et six hommes
issus de divers milieux professionnels,
puis huit femmes travailleuses du sexe.
Les assistants et les assistantes
sexuels mettent leur corps
en contact sensuel et sexuel,
avec le corps de la personne
handicapée contre rémunération.
Leur palette de prestations intimes
sont larges et d’une grande beauté.
J’ai souhaité vous dévoiler ces quelques
confidences pour élargir votre regard
sur des corps dysmorphiques
qui désirent et qui aiment,
au cœur d’une société et de cette société
qui se joue de performance sexuelle
et d’esthétique en excellence.
Par ailleurs,
j’ai découvert combien
la créativité affective et sexuelle
des personnes handicapées est courageuse.
Elles n'ont rien à perdre.
Combien elle est aussi originale.
Parfois, un peu désarmante
parce que atypique.
Drôle aussi.
Et puis, je pense profondément
qu’elle a quelque chose
à nous apprendre de nous-mêmes.
Peut-être plus particulièrement lorsque
nous sommes confrontés nous-mêmes
à nos manques et à nos propres pannes.
Enfin, si vous souhaitiez
savoir comment Jérôme,
Andreas et Clara, Franca et
le jeune homme raconté par son père
ont continué de cheminer,
ce serait avec plaisir.
(Applaudissements)